Hello, everyone, and happy Halloween! I'm Melissa, and welcome back to Psych2Go.
First off, I really want to say "thank you" to everyone who watched my first video
and I'm glad you guys liked it and I hope you like this one just as much.
The article I'm going to be talking about is "Rejected: how does parental rejection after coming out impact us."
This article hits pretty close to home for me. Not because I've been rejected by my parents,
but because I know people who have been rejected by their parents.
*inhale* Now, rejection is a pretty hard thing to deal with, but it's specially difficult when it's coming from parents.
It's sad to say that a lot of people who come out to their parents experience some form of rejection,
whether it would be a form of physical violence, invalidation, or emotional, or financial support.
But how exactly does this impact the mental health of those who are rejected?
The writer of this article, Eva Woodward, worked with Jay Puckett and... Ethan Mereish - I believe,
if that's incorrect, I'm really sorry - uh, she met the two of them through the LGBT Health Summer Institute,
to answer this question: "How does parental rejection when coming out lead to psychological distress
for sexual minorities folks?" They survey two hundred and forty one (241) sexual minorities individuals
across the United States from 2010 to 2012. What they found is that a person who is rejected by their parents
is more likely to think negatively about themselves, and that that person is more likely to experience
depression, anxiety, and thoughts of suicide. Now, there could be some limitations to the research.
They only surveyed two hundred and forty one people, which (while that is a decent number),
is fairly small is comparison to the entire GLBT community. Also, they asked people to look back at
on their experiences, and for some people, over several years, so it's hard to say that this is the exact path
parental rejection to mental health problems. Even so, it's very important that we learn from their results.
So, what about you guys? Have you or anyone you know ever been rejected by your parents because of
your sexuality? And how did that have an impact on you?
Finishing this video up, I would like to say that if you or anybody you know is having any kind of trouble,
or is experiencing thoughts of suicide, to please call the national suicide prevention lifeline
As always, if you like this video, and you'd like to see more videos with me in them, go ahead and
click "thumb up" button and subscribe. Also, don't forget to check out our Tumblr, Facebook and Twitter pages.
Thank you all so much for watching, and have a happy Halloween!